ils soirée insolite au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 25
professionnels de la piste de la route
se sont affrontés devant plus de 3000
personnes à l'occasion de la deuxième
édition du gala star en piste c'est la
fête du vélo il ya très très peu
d'organisation cyclisme sur piste qui
réunit autant de partenaires autant de
public autant de serveurs donc c'est une
super super soirée avec beaucoup
d'animations c'est un événement
particulier entre les les coureurs sur
route
les pistards les féminines c'est quand
même un super rendez vous pour la région
pour la piste que j'ai aussi m'entraîner
ici temps en temps c'est vrai que les
organisateurs font quelque chose de bien
donc c'est ça nous tient à coeur sur la
piste plusieurs épreuves du scratch des
éliminations encore en course à
l'américaine
au-delà de l'aspect sportif les
organisateurs voulaient proposer du
spectacle au public dans une ambiance
familiale en format qui a convaincu les
coureurs pour moi qui ai connu des
grosses
les grosses échéances sportives jeux
olympiques ou les championnats du monde
c'est vrai que c'est quand même un ton
en dessous mais bon aujourd'hui l'état
d'esprit c'est bonne ambiance et
convivialité mais bon on est tous des
compétiteurs donc on va peut-être se
bagarrer un peu sur la piste aussi on
sort d'un gros sites de compétition l'a
fait vraiment un esprit de détente et
mais voilà faire montrer un beau un beau
cyclisme et voilà que les aubades à une
troisième édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine mais cette fois ci le
format pourrait évoluer et durer
plusieurs jours consécutifs sur la piste
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines